Hello, how are you, greetings, Andrés González,
with your brief informative for today,
Wednesday, August 11, the Nevada
Highway and Highway Patrol regularly joins together
to organize a
blood donation event in tribute to
the deceased agent, My Meat, this will be today
at 10:00 p.m.  tomorrow at 5 pm at
the xvii training center located
on sunset road near the dictator
boulevard an appointment is recommended
and if you will be entertainment is looking for
employees the company plans to hire
for more than 300 positions in its 9
strip properties  de las vegas the
job fair will be Thursday from 10 in the
morning to 2 in the afternoon you must fill out the
online application first for all
the details visit our page of
news now dotcom section in Spanish
and if you are eligible for the vaccine
against colli  and you still don't know about clinics
around the valley, we'll tell you that there
will be two from four to six in the afternoon
at baker high schools and the other
today in the morning  na from 9 to 11 inside the
golden nugget hotel and casino and on thursday
and friday there will be another two at the
schools faces of field from 4 to 6 in the
afternoon
we turn to the weather forecast and
we will have a sunny day with a slight
chance of rain there  more
chances of drizzle in the
mountains and in the south of the valley the
temperatures will reach 105 degrees and
even more heat is expected in the next few
days have a nice day I greet you
andrés gonzález and this was about the
news now in Spanish
[Music  ]